ladies and gentlemen welcome to a modern
wisdom Christmas special for those of
you who are probably in the
99.5% that have joined within the last
two and a bit years you won't recognize
this location this is my living room in
Newcastle this is where we did the first
ever in-person episodes with John and YF
and we've got George Mack with us as
well over from Dubai especially just for
this not for Christmas or to see his
parents just for this just for this
episode who to thank it and uh we're all
in for those that
can't see we're all festively adorned in
Christmas jumpers and Yousef is refusing
even though he's hot refusing to take it
off
because it may have to happen halfway
thanks for the
reminder the microphone for the for the
podcast the podcast yeah uh you may
because you complain that it feels like
a hair shirt so you need something to
protect you underneath it's a stoic
torture device just really trying to
build up my willpower it's resilience
training this Christmas jumper is
resilience training anyway we're going
to go through some of our best lessons
and life hacks from the last 12 months
for those of you that haven't heard a
life hacks episode before we go round in
a little Loop and to go through some of
the most best way to make a toasted
sandwich some new app that we've become
obsessed by some new productivity system
or a book or something that we've been
watching and as is tradition Johnny
there it is hot potato for you to go
first is the toasted sandwich one one
you cuz that was mine do you remember
that one bring was brevel toasted
sandwich maker it was a sleeve that you
put bread in to a toaster to toast the I
mean it's it's average to be honest but
you remember it more than me we've done
hundreds and hundreds of life hacks over
the last and that's the one you remember
that's one that I remember anyway first
up what you got so mine's a it's a
supplement and it's one that I think you
feel very strongly about don't know what
the other two guys think clear away
specifically the raspberry lemonade
flavor okay mixed with either lemon or
orange element salts that's interesting
I would genuinely have that over
anything else that's a sophisticated
blend it is it's great so using that
post training just morning first thing
in the morning 30 grams of protein and
some salt sometimes Two Scoops Two
Scoops sometimes Two Scoops raspberry
flavor raspberry lemonade uh and what's
that 50 55 grams of I don't even know
yeah enough that's good yeah and why you
why that it's just I don't know like I I
mean I'll get into this later in the
episode when we talk about lessons but
I've been big on this year is all about
set things to background make something
fun align the like what you should do
with that was nice I think I was
thinking about this the other day that
that hosi uh clip that I had with him
where was explaining my love for pickle
ball because it's 1,000 calories in 90
minutes and all you're doing is chasing
a ball yeah like trying to get the thing
whereas the guy that sits on the cross
trainer for 990 minutes thinking to him
oh I'm so disciplined with David Goggins
playing in his ear the outcome for both
of us has been precisely the same except
he's had to develop so much more and use
so much more willpower if you take like
I don't know
2009 me I'd be still trying to get
protein and hydration and lemon and
water and salt and all sort of stuff
first as soon as I wake up and it's like
oh egg whites and whereas that's like a
delicious way to wake up so the
principle behind that that I think is
that there's no moral virtue in white
Ling everything so ramit setti talks
about that with just automating your
saving if you just have a direct debit
that or a standing order whatever the
international phrases for that for
savings to just go out as soon as you
get paid you're then not having to think
each month oh I really need to save
whatever you just never see it it's just
well they do that with uh is it pension
contributions they realize that they
could get people to increase the
contribution to their pension easier
when they ask them to do it at the time
that they got a pay rise
because as yet they'd never realized the
gains from that new paycheck and as a
part of that people didn't feel
anchoring bias largely right oh here's
new money but it's a little bit less new
money than you were thinking you were
getting as opposed to old money now
minus some so is the key there that
you've got to forget about it you've got
to be able because if you save if you're
saving automatically and you aren't
aware of it that's the win isn't it cuz
you don't notice whereas if you think
I've got a pay rise you just squander it
before it even comes in and usually
people overcorrect it's like I've done
30 minutes of cardio I'm going to have a
couple of donuts you've just more than
corrected for the calories it's also
automation right yeah doing whatever the
hard thing is there's some in that
though that you said then of the thing
that you like with a pickle ball for
example and uh it's like U jovic versus
Andre Agy have you ever heard that thing
so Andre Agy became world number one
went all the way down to like 120 was
doing crazy drugs like hated tennis
loads of childhood trauma but was
constantly grinding it away and then
they asked jovic like
what about you and he goes I just like
hitting the ball and if you can find
where you like hitting the ball versus
having to go Onre aesy mode such cont so
Aaron Alexander who is my American
equivalent of Usef is literally is I'd
love to know what that means Andre i'
would love to meet you if you're very
into very into Bodywork very gamey like
if I grab his lat unbelievably gay me
like do you know it's like a really yeah
does tons tons of body work um we were
doing high side planks you know where
you've got you up on that and then
you've got your other hand up as well
it's pretty unable where your yeah arms
like this and he looked over at me and
he could say I was gritting my teeth in
the middle of this workout and he just
said what would this be like if it was
easier what would this be like if it was
a [__] awesome principle and you're
like all right like I don't need to grip
as hard to this thing there's times when
you should do that you trying to max out
your deadlift yeah but for the most part
what would this thing I'm trying to
achieve be like if it was easier like if
you don't like your morning walk pick a
better route if you don't like the drink
that you have to have first thing in the
morning find another brand or find a
different flavor until you find the one
that you actually enjoy if you don't
like getting your steps in buy a dog
yeah well I don't think many people like
normal whey protein just to link it back
to my point I think a loads of people
drink whey protein with like yeah
whereas clear way delicious Game Changer
mate genuinely delicious all right Seth
you're up so life hack to begin with I'm
excited about this cuz I've been working
with a team of accountants and
operational analysts to develop the
optimal categorization system for life
hacks and what they've landed on is
basically digital and physical life
hacks so I'm going to begin with a
physical
one which I got from my partner which is
if you have I love how you had to take
the glasses off like this is [__]
down to business
serious if you eat a lot of berries like
me get yourself a Pyrex Tupperware with
a sealable lid and they last days longer
like they no longer you know you would
be like a turgid plump blueberry that's
not kind of a bit deflated and crap you
just it maintains that for five six days
cuz most of the packaging for berries
has got little perforations in the top
of the seal right is that not there for
a reason so soon I I mean I don't know
what their reason is I think because
like there's a difference between what
you just revolutionized the ber industry
forever there someone some someone from
Kia Aura listening going how didn't we
think about this so there's maybe a
difference between the way things are
stored in a supermarket for display
versus at home so eggs and things are
stored differently but Beres give it a
try do you ever get frozen berries I do
but not quite as good they don't quite
land as well do they M well they haven't
got the the snap yeah agreed uh I mean
finding the right blueberries is a it's
a difficult a difficult challenge I've
found that you can go super small and
they're Tangy and take take your face
off you can make you go
like uh and then if you go too big
there's never big and turgid and
turgidity is what I optimize for it's
the triangle isn't it so you get to pick
two of three so there's taste turgid and
size and you can only be on one of the
vertices of the
triangle it's a real
shame this is the sort of thing you wake
up and think about in the morning I've
got a model for it yeah it's in my
second tick uh all right my one so this
is an old one the OG listeners of which
it's literally like points of a percent
that will have heard this one before so
all of this is essentially new to
everyone but it's one that I really
reinforced again this year and has just
continued to pay dividends I would
probably say top five life hacks of all
time wow text your friends when you're
thinking about them just it continues to
pay huge [__] dividends why is
everyone laughing is there a limit so
let's say you think about someone five
or six times in a day because it's a
self- exciting process isn't it once you
think of someone you're more likely to
think of them again that day but if you
keep texting them that day they're going
to be like all right Chris like this is
the Yousef who at 5 years old organized
all of his toy trucks in a perfect
semicircle by size and then color coming
out just just to be sure are we is it
every time that I think about evidently
not like use use a filter of let's not
be a crazy person so if there's any
programmers or developers listening to
this you've actually clarified a caveat
quite importantly but no just when
you're thinking about someone just send
them a message like whatever it is you
know we'll do it all the time like
remember that thing or even just a link
to whatever it is that we did previously
that's resurfaced somewhere cuz you
think about your friends way more than
you're in contact with them and they
never get to benefit from it by sending
them a text saying hey mate just
thinking about you hope everything's
good or a memory about what it is that
you're doing or whatever it is that's
surfaced in your mind it makes them feel
great because it's just nice to be
reminded of that it makes you feel good
because you've unselfishly just bestowed
some you know love onto whoever it is
and it keeps friendships ticking over if
if your friends knew how often you
thought of them friendships would DEC
pay much more slowly than they actually
do and by doing this you actually reduce
that gap between the two things I mean
this is something that you've done as
well right this year trying to do better
yes yeah yeah yeah you are chronically
bad with your phone which is actually
being very good with your phone yeah
yeah that that is the tough balance with
the one you've given there of I try not
to be on my phone too much and then I'll
end up in that sloof of texting back and
forth but the reason that you try not to
be on your phone is not because of
texting your friends texting is actually
one of the if you had to like draw a
graph of Roi activities texting friends
on the top it's the same as why you
actually got me back into taking photos
at events I'd mistakenly thought that
taking a photo was cringe because the
only reason you take a photo so you
could post it on Instagram so I
asssociated taking photos of things that
you enjoyed with being a cringe in
Instagram poster but it's actually I can
take a photo and not post it anywhere
and it's my memory for me so I had to
like chop that bit off very animportant
distinction yeah I have a recurring
reminder at different cadences for
friends to check in on them give them a
call Etc so it's like Geo tag oh yeah
Geo tag so if I'm in certain cities it
pings up with like oh I'm in London get
in touch with Ali get in touch with
whoever I'm immediately picturing Yousef
like actioning this life hack and I'm
going to get a text from like yousef's
VA saying you usf's in the back thinking
about something like that very soon had
a very strict Cadence very strict
Cadence always at 9:00 p.m. at night
I think I still need to reply to a
message from you from like June there we
go do it do it live on the podcast do do
now I I wrestle with the worry that as
soon as you message someone if they
reply straight away now you're that
could be 20 minutes back and
forth do you know do not like your
friends no I do but that but but I think
you've opened up a a bottomless task
yeah so like similar to you I'm like ah
I should text Chris M and you're you're
good at it you'll reply and then that's
it we about our exchange but some people
are like oh hey may oh this postle
pillow talk yeah yeah like I was just
doing my task man like well I don't know
I've got a final question for you on
this because I know Johnny is very
easygoing on this if someone knows that
you have a an internal system for every
time someone every time you think of
someone you have to text them every time
sure but does that ruin the magic I
don't think so should it seem
spontaneous cuz I have a reminder for
all my friends birthdays and so on and
some people will be like oh well that's
not the same you know you're not just
doing it out of your own whereas
Johnny's like oh no I think that's great
because you've had the foresight so I
think you're you're one of having
reminders is less emergent my one is
when you think of a friend text them
like that there's no no point in there
is there any deceit right I was just
thinking about you hope that
everything's well like you've said
what's happening your one is hi
mate well well no it depends on why it's
like hey mate my reminder just came up
telling me to message you do you say
that
well yeah good point so if you say that
the magic's gone precisely so you're one
it's knowing how you do the magic trick
isn't it yeah yeah yeah I'm now just
going to check my phone every day and if
you've not messaged me I haven't thought
of you count maybe I think of you so
much that I can't that it's more than
once a day right George you can't my
one's s my one is
um
[__] oh it's thrown me that's really
he said no private jokes yeah that
explaining that's not private everyone's
seen you're I actually had some BBC
so and enough for the Alan par
references my one is going to um
three-fold one I think it's going to um
add years on to men's lives reduce the
divorce rate and it also killed my fear
of dying alone so um I had very low bar
to get yeah I had this simultaneous fear
that for ages I wouldn't be able to
share a bed with anybody because I would
constantly get woken up throughout the
night and it's like what point in the
dating process do you bring that up of
like we're going to have separate beds
so I just assumed that it wouldn't work
out and there was this image on Reddit
for people who haven't seen
it where a boyfriend and girlfriend
track their sleep for like over a year
and both of them the top two are very
similar so fasted in bed uh 3 hours
before bed um is a 16% Improvement in
sleep getting in bed before 11:00 p.m.
both of them that was the two most
beneficial factors
and then for her a beneficial Factor was
sharing bed with partner and then you go
all the way down his list through all
the good ones all the way past alcohol
all the way past like everything bad you
can think of the single biggest thing
minus 25% score was sharing bed with a
partner however for her it was plus 7%
so she benefits from it meanwhile he's D
and for context girls her men trting was
minus 15% so double that him yeah him
sharing be with the part with her was
was way worse careful with this sorry
was way worse than uh her menstrating is
there a hack here George or is this I
know I already know what's coming the
end of this
movie you're screw might change this
might change your life can I can I ask
around the room do you sleep better or
worse when a partner's in the bed way
worse what about yourself worse what
about yourself I don't feel my date is
good enough to answer the question I'd
say it doesn't affect me okay well
whenever I not with a partner in the bed
it's like in a hotel traveling yeah and
that's worse anyway okay so there's yeah
there's not enough I mean The
evolutionary explanation would be you
naturally men tend to sleep near the
door anyway on average for these
relationships you're then thinking if
somebody breaks it and whenever she
moves the duvet your adrenaline goes up
and her adrenaline goes down because
she's like oh he's that double duvet is
the life hack two duve Scandinavian
style I tried it and it's it is the best
I've okay so we need to really dig into
this you sleep in a king Super King
Super King Super King which is actually
only in real size two singles side by
side I mean it might be if that feels
smaller it's not a king right okay I
think a king is actually two singles
right anyway Super King so how would you
do it he has a super king bed yeah you
can't have two Super King dues so do you
get two double dues yeah sizewise you
can play around with that
just two your I don't know yeah but it's
like saying oh my iPhone I don't know
the exact iPhone case for your iPhone
right however just never had an iPhone
George's first life act he wasn't
prepared for the level of autism that we
don't tie me up in legal
e oh what uh what size bed do you have
again Super King just get two Super King
dues but then that's ridiculous two
Super King dues it's going to be on the
floor think about it it's going to be
like so much baggy do it's still we'll
go King then go King but two kings
getting caught up in the details what
this details details for me with the
details okay
okay unbelievable um I really think I
really think that this this needs I mean
we can put this out to millions and
millions of people I would go as far as
to say probably two double dues if you
have a super king if you have a super
king what we need is a PDF nice PDF can
you supplemental appendices please all
the guys who sleep with their girlfriend
or wife have to go listen to this
episode and then sell it to someone
don't they that's true I think George
said because of my courtis all so on
that that we need two do and say how big
are the dues I forgot to do the followup
which was then when they track the
double duvet it was the single biggest
positive thing for him oh so the data
seems to suggest that do you have two D
I've been in the process of negot ating
this since visiting
George what's being the issue with
negotiation just that she thinks it's a
bit antisocial antisocial antisocial
yeah but I think two singles will do
because but we're in a king and if a
king is truly two single beds that's the
perfect I think you're going to want I
think you're going to want a little bit
more I think you're Queen I think you're
going to want two queens two doubles two
doubles on a normal King is going to be
a
lot is a double not smaller than is a
queen smaller than a double the amount
of bandwidth given to this that's why I
need it's important yeah there'll be a
PDF at some point we need a matrix and a
PDF yeah I mean this is another thing
it's how do you sell it to the
partnerd my answer has just been buying
the extra duvet and then just going in
the do this is the way we sleep
now yeah
and I discovered it by accident because
I I read that data Didn't Do It um and
then stayed in a hotel where there was
like a blanket extra like a duvet extra
um and it was magical I went from waking
up five to six times a night to n they
were using AA I think Aura yeah they
were on aura that is annoy make yourself
a custom journal entry and let's split
test this year's time no you just use
something that it isn't something yeah
likeing or
something skiing uh all right so lessons
first one from you my God I thought we
were doing life ha I was ready for one
Loop of life hacks one Loop of lessons
keep it variety Okie
doy um just before we actually get
started with that do you remember I know
exactly where I was at a set of traffic
lights when I texted both of you this
years ago I wanted to do something I
think it was called like
um like lesson lesson hacks or like life
lessons it was life lessons and I was
like why don't we do a series of life
lessons as well as life hacks which is
kind of what we're going to go through
here and I seem to remember you saying
something along the lines of like that's
a big shout to presume that we're
sufficiently interesting to actually
bestow lessons on anybody MH and uh so I
bailed out of doing that but a couple of
years later all of the listicle style
episodes that I do like the hosi style
one uh the ones that me and George do if
it's a list of mental models all of that
that is the progeny of originally what I
was thinking about doing from life
lessons and um I think it probably
wasn't time at the time but I'm I reckon
now we're we've ascended to be I thought
that was you're the most requested guest
on the podcast as well
so according
to my
brain you want to listen to me on the
podcast the most I would listen to you
talking life lessons you get you get to
talk to me all the time oh it's getting
hot I'm so my first lesson is actually
from ukis okay really recently and it's
linked to what George has just said so
if anyone's listened to life hacks from
the very beginning I've been on a real
journey
with tracking devices Fitbit Ora whoop
borrowed your aura ring years ago didn't
like it that much you it was you said
you summed up I think what the whole
point of all these things is which was
you said something like it's not about
how recovered you are or what your score
is it's just how much sleep you get MH
and I think the point what I've learned
from all that stuff this year CU we've
had as we'll get on to we've had a
fairly like jarring year where I've
realized like if I don't prioritize
the recovery side I'm so focused on the
activity side the training side the step
side but I never like the sleep and the
recovery like I always push to one side
but having something to just remind you
every day like you should have a na
player like you're taking the piss like
if you keep doing this is going to get
worse and worse and worse so having a
recovery tracker or something external
to prompt you to like you are not
prioritizing this and if you don't
prioritize it it's a problem it's going
to Scupper you yeah yeah you're going to
I mean this I'm aware that I'm both a
whoop and eight sleep partner so this is
maybe not great for my partnership with
them but I can give you the the only
takeaway that everybody that has one of
those learns you're sleeping less than
you think you are yeah yeah you're
sleeping less than like it's just whoop
Conant you're sleeping less than you
think you are like sleeping less than
you think you are should be the tagline
yeah honestly and it all that you get
from tracking your sleep is [__] I I was
in bed I was sure that I was in bed for
for 8 hours turns out it was actually
sort of 7:15 and of that 7:15 my
efficiency was 85% which means I got 6
hours and 30 minutes of sleep last night
and I thought I got eight hours it's
just that over and over and over and
over and over again well you need to be
in bed for 9 hours don't you to get
eight yeah abely and now you're going to
have double duve think about what 204 is
going
to yeah I just it's such a there's a
good quote on that which I think I
forgot who said it but um there's no
such thing as being overworked there's
just underr so true so
true yeah I'm yet to find I'm yet to
find a time where I've been overworked
if just under arrested yes just under
rested yeah if I get a good night's
sleep and
train there's pretty much no amount of
work are you being serious have you
finished that no no I'm just plowing
through the decided to like there's an
obvious ad there just was like trying to
make eye contact to do it the same time
um cuz do you guys what do you guys do
you use whoop do you just do you just
wing it with sleep I mix it up I've used
uh whoop I've used Aura it depends on
like different periods if I want to test
thing the one thing that can happen is
begin to have like a reverse Placebo
where if I have a bad night's sleep and
then I check it I feel like I've had an
even worse night sleep I think dis for
the whoop users completely disregarding
a recovery score is a good idea so that
that was a quote it you said you
literally said to me we were walking to
egg [__] in London and you said it's not
how recovered you are how much sleep you
got 100% And it's just I know it's so
simple but I'm so focused on like oh
it's Amber to day got eight and a half
hours of sleep bro I got so I slept
through my flight sorry I stayed awake
through my flight from Austin back to
the UK which means that I 8 hours had
lasted me for 2 days not good dying all
day yesterday I got tracked on whoop 11
hours of sleep last night so that's
probably like 11 and 1 half with a
little bit of awakeness but I'm only at
40% recovered like hey get [__] right
I had 11 hours of sleep last night I
feel great today regardless of where my
HIV and my resting heart rat's at and
then there's a self-fulfilling prophecy
that if you're told that you slept badly
you start telling yourself the story
that oh maybe I and then you perform
worse and there's studies that confirm
that that if you're um if people are
told falsely that they've slept badly
they perform worse on cognitive tests
than if they
just no sleep bow so I I think you the
way you've done gone about it is great
because you've identified what is the
Keystone needle mover which is Total
Sleep time there's a lot tracking
devices have a lot of redundant
data excellent um they do have a lot of
redundant data and so my medical
training is very much drilled into me
that you don't test what you're not
looking for because if you just do a
panel of blood tests on someone who's
asymptomatic and something's out of
whack what do you thing you've now got a
thing that you have to deal with and you
don't have a context for being able to
put it into into the context of the
symptoms that they're dealing with so
and it adds to the bandwidth as well
doesn't it if you if you test loads of
things all at once if you have a smart
meter for example and it tells you this
is how much energy I'm using now and
this is how much it's costing me well is
that really going to change my behavior
or have I just added to the open Loops
in my head of something that isn't
helping I like that I like it it's yeah
so I suppose the summary is put less
attention on tracking like the other
side of the equation because you
probably do that well depends who's
listening which is the problem with
these things but if you're the sort of
person who wears a w band you're
probably handling the activity side and
you probably ignore you're like I'm
green recovered but I got 6 hours of
sleep and actually the biggest change is
just is just volume of sleep focus on
sleep right Seth lessons lesson lessons
so as Johnny said we've had quite a
turbulent year what do you tell us about
that what you both the I guess the main
thing is that from this time last year
to now the team has gone from two people
to 19 people which along along with that
comes a lot of operational complexity a
whole bunch of skill sets that Johnny
and I just didn't have that we have to
suddenly develop we set up propane about
10 years ago well 14 years ago and we're
very much like skitso introvert type
characters that just like to be at our
desks doing our own thing and we barely
even communicate with each other we're
just like in the hole you're annoying
well um so we're just kind of in the
hole doing our thing and suddenly it's
like oh there's a team and we have to
learn to let go of a lot of the
processes that normally we'd be handling
ourselves so the lesson has been that
when you're especially running a
business it's like an accelerated
version of this and I know you've been
thrown into this
is that it's as James CLE says it's a
vessel for self-improvement disguised as
a money-making Enterprise that it's the
the biggest driver of your personal
growth because it comes in and just
twists your nipples and finds all of the
the the spots that you've got your
trigger points and it will force you to
level up and to learn those skill sets
and to grow well it's external to you
all personal growth is always done at
your own pace but the business isn't so
it yeah it forces you along Road running
versus running on a treadmill yeah
you're getting steamrolled and it's like
a heat-seeking missile as well cuz it
finds all of the things that would get
you emotionally triggered or wound up MH
so a difficult client or getting working
late nights or getting stressed about a
potential I don't know legal case or
whatever it is be more agreeable or
disagreeable learning to disappoint
people fear that it'll go away fear that
it'll fail feel you like people down
fear of how how people think of you
they're all 10 out of 10 aren't they
business is vehicle for personal growth
disguised as a wealth making machine
that's [__] brilliant is that in
atomic abits don't think it is not sure
one of his tweets I think one of the uh
biggest hacks um I've found for that is
documentation so let's say if you write
quite a lot about anxiety and all the
stuff when you when you got when you get
that fourth employee and you've doubled
the head count and if you can now go
back at 19 and review those thoughts of
like how worried you was and anxious you
was and you go oh and you can see the
evidence of you now going I've now
almost 5x that um it makes it a lot
easier to then play that again going
look how anxious I was then and I
figured it out it's constant evidence
whereas in business there's no like
Instagram account for it so like trying
to create as much documentation is and
especially between you two guys as well
to be able to share it is oh yeah we
look back and think remember that thing
that we thought was a massive problem
you know what would be you know it would
be a really good way to do this a slack
CH a private slack Channel that's just
got you two in where you can just brain
dump [__] to each other like dude I'm
feeling a little bit whatever whatever
about today and that's all that goes in
there and that would be the journal
between especially if you got a business
partner going to be tougher for the solo
preneurs I remember it's in my day one
so day one for me is serious [__] right
it's like there's a per been periods of
three years where nothing's gone in
there's been periods of six weeks where
I've documented three times day one is
for like [__] hell like something
really dramatic has happened I remember
there's it's still [__] in there
there's this one where
the MC for room two upstairs in the R&B
room of voodoo Saturdays at Riverside
told me that he was leaving to go to a
competing club night in Sunderland and I
felt that that was Salient enough to put
in my [__] day one right that was the
beginning of the thing that was going to
be the Snowball Effect that would cause
the first off the like Asian sock wasn't
going to come anymore because he was
their favorite MC and then after Asian
sock went obviously all of the other
dominoes were going to Tumble and I was
going to be homeless alone on a street
and I was going to get gluten
intolerance and live under a bridge
gluten
intolerance but that's perfectly
appropriate because at the time you were
just reacting to the circumstances as
you found them and it was a hot button
for you like that's the thing that
tapped into this golden thread of like
I'm going to be under a bridge I'm going
to get gluten intolerance I'm going to
have all these it's like so that was
like a real hot button then and as you
say it's great to come back to that and
be
like just have you seen day one has this
Fe of the on this day feature yes yeah I
don't have enough I don't have enough
entries so I try and use it I just after
I meditate I just write what's on my
mind and if you just always what there
pretty much always if you do it often
enough is an on this day on this day 8
years ago 10 years ago 12 years ago and
he just like God there's so many like
recurrent things going have to bank both
of those comments for my next round cuz
you guys are front running one of my
other lessons so again like one of the
worst life hack episodes is when two
different people arrived and had done
the same life KN hack and then you got
[__] [__] [__] [__] um all right so
my first one it's cool that we're got
this sort of Human Centipede of ideas
coming on here the um this is from you
which is Max content razor would you
consume your own content if not don't
post it and that inspired post content
Clarity which is your content diet
should be Spirulina for the soul not
fast food for your amigdala and um what
realized was that when you're consuming
anything on the Internet it's almost
always it tends toward limic hijack
because if it didn't you would watch
something else which was more lytically
hijacking you know what I mean so during
the moment of consuming pretty much
anything this podcast included you are a
bad judge of whether or not that piece
of content is good for you or not
because it's just compelling but what
you can do is have a sort of Pillow Talk
post kitle review of how did that
particular session of YouTube watching
or Tik Tok scrolling or Instagram
browsing make me feel and was there
anything in there that is better or
worse and if there's stuff that
continues to come in as worse it's like
unfollow not interested in this channel
don't recommend to me again does all of
the all of the social medias have a way
of down voting as well as up voting uh
channels and you can get rid of them you
can hide them from your feed you can do
all the rest of the stuff and if you
hide something from your feed it's tant
amount to that entire worldview or that
Creator just die right it's L the same
so unfollowing is great isn't it like
there are people who just they always
come up on your feed and they annoy you
and then when you unfollow them it's
like yeah or even muting you know if you
can't if there's some you know
interpersonal reason why you can't get
away with the unfollow just muting
accounts that you don't like I had this
when I always struggled with Instagram
delete it download it d d du go back and
forth with it and I had this realization
one day of like this three four question
of like did this educate me no okay move
on to next question question did this
like entertain me or make me laugh so if
it's like an Allan Partridge thing or a
funny meme it stays on if no moves on to
the next list of do I want to see this
person in the next six months if no mute
and that it takes about 12 hours of
pruning like um or like a day and a half
of pruning just whenever you're on and
immediately the newsfeed is infinitely
better that is the one thing about the
people complain about the 4 You
algorithms that they're filter bubbles
but you can also create a wonderful
filter bubble if all you do is like
photos of Doc
you will just have a feed of docs well
we're training the algorithms on what we
actually want but the problem is that
what we want in the moment is not what
we want to want after the moment
retrospectively we wish that we were
watching more of X or Y or Zed one
interesting thing I think that's
happening with YouTube is I think they
have time based recommendations so at
different times of the day different
things get recommended to me based on my
viewing habits so I tend to listen to
World War II documentaries which Shane
Gillis calls early onset Republican like
getting getting interested in history
documentaries he's like yo if your man
starts watching World War II
documentaries Gateway keep an it is a
gateway drug it's early onset Republican
um but I do that but it only recommends
them to me at night first thing in the
morning it's not middle of the day it's
always 10 minute to 15 minute videos
that I can watch with my lunch so again
just train the algo but yeah um and then
for the content creators or fledgling
cont content creators out there this is
something that I'm battling with at the
moment there are ways to play the
algorithm and there are ways to add
value and there are things that you want
to do and between within those three
prongs is some balance of what you have
to do you have to play Within the limits
of the algo or else you're just going to
be shouting Into The Ether but you don't
want to be completely controlled by it
because that's just audience capture
there is ways of having impact but you
can sacrifice reach and what you want to
do and then that's also that's kind of a
more virtuous version but still a kind
of audience capture and then there's
what you want to do which can be like
just total solipsism like self
masturbatory congrat congratulatory
Glory but that's also not playing the
game so somewhere in all of them is
where you want to be but not leaning too
far to just what does the audience want
and what will get lots of plays because
if you wouldn't consume it what the [__]
are you doing and I realized this at the
live shows I was doing this tour I would
happily go for a beer with any of the
people that arrived and I know for a
[__] fact that there are tons of
podcasters who couldn't say the same
like they're not making an audience of
people that are like them or people that
are cool or people that are interesting
and every single person that came up to
me I was like [__] like I'd happily
like GO train with this person or go for
a coffee with this person or whatever
they're all interesting they're all
killing it they're all in good shape
they're all like cool or whatever in
some form or another and yeah would you
consume your own content if not don't
post it it's just it slices through all
of the [__] do you think there's a
do you think the people who listen to
your podcast are you but like a previous
version of I think like you have to make
content for what would 5 years ago
listen to or or watch rather cuz I
assume what you want to watch now is
different is probably a little bit
different right so yeah um but I also
think that if you were posting what you
10 years ago needed it wouldn't be a few
steps ahead of where you were so you can
still frame things in the learnings that
you've had you know all of us have been
shaped by your time in a big four
accounting firm your time as a doctor
your time in a bunch of different
agencies or moving to London to go do
this thing so you talk where you're at
but you frame it with where you've been
and I think that that helps people to
get along in the steps this is an Ali
abdal thing where he said you don't want
to teach people who are 10 steps behind
you because you can't remember the
problems that you had 10 steps ago you
want to teach people that are sort of
three or four steps behind you because
it gives them the path it allows you to
still be within that purview but this is
you know a reason for tracking the
journey again as we said about taking
photos about noting things down because
if you don't track the journey all of
those learnings are just lost and you
can't remember the things that were only
Salient to you 5 years ago as
revolutionary because now they're taken
for granted you see that with like
wealth gurus so that Grant Cardone
saying oh yeah when you're buying
companies you really need to figure
remember that this is a it's like for a
regular person off the street or talking
about how you're going to um rent your
fourth holiday home in Andor like it
it's stuff that's so far removed from
and it's like aggravated his life yeah
cuz you're like well what do I do with
that yeah do you think think that a
possible pressure valve that CU I see a
lot of YouTubers that will have a second
channel for that kind of monologue
uncensored unfiltered whatever do you
think that's just for them to scratch
the itch of content they want to create
but they don't want to post on the main
Channel that's interesting well there's
lots of second channels that are also
dog [__] like like they they they still
don't add value I heard this term a
little while ago I probably need you
guys to help spin this up uh growth
hacking relatability or speedrunning
authenticity and a lot of people try to
do that it's like what what are the ways
that I can make self seem more authentic
or relatable than I am but it's one of
these things that's just it's like the
speed of light it's like you are as
authentic as you are authentic and
trying to growth hack authenticity
results in you seeming even less
authentic the Brian Rose effect right
like [__] Shadow Boxing under a
bridge with degenerate skateboarders
looking for a bare Market in a bush
like he is oh God he
is
me and George I we'll I'll can I tell
them the story about that day we did VR
oh yeah go right okay so uh what what
were we here for uh what were we in town
for Ark no I can't even remember we were
in we came to we've been we've been back
and forth so many times we came to
London for some event and we had a day
and I had some mushrooms with me some
magic mushroom capsules so me and George
decided to do two we we double bubble
bang banged the world's two most
Advanced virtual reality experiences
Jeff Wayne's War of the Worlds at dot
dot dot in London and then the Tower of
London virtual reality experience uh we
did those back toback on mushrooms so if
you think that mushrooms is crazy
mushrooms in VR with a
full like cast of actors around you for
two hours twice in the same day was just
[__] mindblowing that's enough to
induce a psychotic break isn't it we we
I think the dosage was pretty optimal
like we it was like a like a 0.7 0.8
kind of like just like nice little
fluffy thing but it made everything seem
so much more to do both you do one and
you're like I saw I me with Chris today
and I see go what you want do today you
like a walk maybe saw a quick workout he
goes I've got some mushrooms we can go
to a VR world I go guess gu flip a coin
then right so similar yeah yeah it was
[__] brilliant it was a good day what
a day right you're up um my one so um
related to the chat so far so the
content razor that we spoke about then
is very midwit um it's very what is the
simple answer that works and the big
thing for me this year has been the
midwit meme I'm quite obsessive about
the midwit meme because I'm a midwit
I've diagnose myself as a midwit I'm a
recovering midwit I think you have to
say it publicly to start recovering from
it and I did something that was quite
midwit but I think it ends up working
which is like trying to figure out an
algorithm that moves you to the guy on
the to the stupid guy on the left
because if you try and be the genius on
the right that's what the midwit does
whereas what you want to do is simplify
it down of rather than a complex content
strategy of scheduling at 2:30 p.m.
every single day and this editing
strategy from Alex hos it's no would I
consume this so the midwit algorithm is
basically it's what we spoke about in
the first episode but I've kind of
completely neglected it which is just
basic inversion so the biggest takeaway
from me is so let's say I've got like
three examples here so one is writing
one is writing the other is e-commerce
um or like an internet business and the
other one is happiness so for like
writing like the obvious midwit thing
would be to consume the best writers of
all time and find out their specific
morning routines and trying to reverse
it backwards versus with inversion you
just say if you was to make sure you was
a terrible writer what would you do well
the first thing you'd do is you wouldn't
write right the second thing you would
do is you would write in consistently if
you ever did and then the third thing is
actually what you said then which is
you'd write about things you didn't like
to write about I think there's a you
would you would do things that make you
feel like you're making progress toward
writing that aren't writing yes exactly
and all of a sudden via just inverting
you found out what the guy on the left
would say it' be like write write
consistently and write what you like and
then even internet businesses where I
see this a lot where people have these
complex Dynamic flows to this chat Bo
that then moves them through this AB
cycle versus if you went okay you wanted
to guarantee an internet business would
fail what would you do well one you'd
have like the world's worst margins so
you'd make like like 0.1% margin we give
you the worst margins possible the
second thing is there's like no repeat
purchase so there's such little LTV and
then and also the average order values
tiny and then there'd be like a zero
principle which would be like you're
selling [__] sandwiches you're selling
something that nobody wants so you'd be
selling [__] with no margin no repeat
part make it really hard to buy make the
site Lo site page speed really later
down the list but it just right now just
[__] sandwiches with no margin no repeat
customer thing is [__] sandwich has got
a bit of a nich PE like the Nazi milk
there we go did we talk about that no
what's that oh it was correct me if I if
this rings a bell or you got it so is a
woman sat doing photo shoots with Nazi
memorabilia all around her and she's got
her feet in some milk and she's bathing
in milk and then bottles it up and sells
it online as Nazi milk and quite a
decent markup on that but again Nicha
peel you think well didn't Bel deline
sell her bath water oh don't know yeah
I'm pretty sure bathe in a bath but
those are both things that people want
actually wanted to buy
anyway we have to milk this podcast
sponsor um so uh and then happiness is
another one where people are doing such
like complex strategies for that and
going to Peru and taking I which again
there's a time and a place for but if
you had to make somebody miserable
terrible sleep terrible diet and
exercise and terrible people and midwit
the way to find out what the guy on the
left would be is just to invert things
around and avoid the top three or
four what is the opposite of success
exactly and avoid avoid those things
what would someone that was going to run
a terrible online fitness B like if you
wanted to try and make the worst online
Fitness business you could what would be
the three things to try to do don't do
them yes yeah because and most sorry
just to put in but most smart people
will get caught up on the 16th smart
thing for success and not avoid those
things including myself we we have a
phrase which is just stay Stupid with
the advice yeah like as soon as you
start trying to make something
complicated like what would the stupid
person do they wouldn't understand the
complexity the difficulty is I think
convincing yourself that the stupid
advice is actually that cuz there's
there's examples of things where it
seems simple but it actually is the
wrong thing to do what like and you
going to ask me okay so going and
training chest every day for example I
want to get in good shape I'm just going
to train chess every day what do I like
to doing I like training chest I'll just
do pec deck every day it that's simple
advice but it's probably not the best
there's a level of being informed that
you need to get you need to like get
just over the like it's like a white
belt mentality right like the white belt
actually does know so all of the [__]
that you learn when you first start
boxing it's like here is how to throw a
good jab guess what you're going to
throw most of during your entire boxing
career Jabs but then when you get to
blue belt syndrome or purple belt
syndrome the equivalent in boxing and
you're like yeah well it's all about
like my back off hand uppercut like
that's really where I'm it's like no no
get [__] this is the way to figure it
out isn't it you look at what are you a
black belt in now and then think back
what was I trying to do when I was a
white belt and I've just come all the
way back to basics and I'm just doing
the basics consistently well Yousef had
one which was someone asked Yousef
recently like what's a like what's his
recommendation for pre-workout nutrition
mhm and he was like H like coffee and
some like honey on toast or something
and he's like that sits on both sides
the coffee and the Honey on toast it's
the first thing you try before you do
your first arm session and then you go
through all the
like
extract bottle I'm going to train later
I'll have some honey on toast and a
coffee I don't know yeah so trying to
find the but it's still informed enough
that it's tell you what useful what's
mental about this is that the first ever
episode that me and George did in your
old old old old offices at Social chain
where we did inversion how do you make
uh it's hard to work out how to be happy
but it's easy to work out how to make a
happy person miserable yes this is one
of the most painful things that I've had
to realize which
is many of the questions that I struggle
with now exist in podcasts I recorded at
some point over the last six years I'm
getting front run
again
but you know what we clearly we clearly
had a very similar 2023 so yeah I mean
it's been I think maybe you just get
disquieted by less stuff than us like
you're you're psychologically more
stable I think than both of us this is
the trend I'm noticing that like here we
are coming up with these half formed
ideas and then George is like well I've
actually got an algorithm for that and a
full process that I've thought about
there is something to be said though
about um making content forgetting that
you made it and then it coming back to
you so like I said so David senra from
Founders recently tagged me in something
where it was there's two kinds of people
on the internet um one that doesn't
understand the scale of the internet and
the
other the other are people that know
they don't understand the scale of the
internet and he then quoted me and I was
like I didn't realize I said that but I
go that's
good so there I went back and found it I
go I did say that uh right so there's
two ways that this happens as well the
first one is you get quoted by someone
saying a thing that you forgot that
you'd said that's level one level
Infinity is you get quoted by people who
attribute quotes to you that you never
said because it seems like it fits so
I've talk all of you guys about this
before but churchillian drift is the
name of the phenomenon whereby
unattributed quotes get attributed to
Churchill more and more over time and
it's like what you want is to develop
like William sonian drift like you want
to insert yourself into a niche whereby
it's people that go don't know who said
that that sounds like a like a Chris
Williamson thing like you got be very
careful with the other chrisam will TR
an yeah well you know this is also where
it would be useful to have a Andrew Tate
esque Army of Vietnamese repurposes just
starting to post quotes with like
unattributed but like supposedly
attributed to Chris Williamson to create
the trend that's how you begin that
tsunami that's great I really like that
one is there anything else on inversion
that's it just um think of the top three
to five things flip it around and youve
figured out how to be the guy on the
left and you will forget those things
time and time again all right Johnny be
the guy on the left am I on hack or
lesson hack
please
uh tick
tick here we go here we
go so right I'm get I'm personally
invested in this one so yeah this is
this is now an ad read for tick tick for
me okay forget the fact that there's a
few million in other other news don't
say that anymore sorry that's all right
don't worry
is it now just news I think we've done
Chris dirty with tick tick haven't we
[__] left me out to dry you hung me
out to dry would you like to tell yes
would you like to tell the story of what
you did to me well I mean I I thought at
the time Chris I was doing the right
thing okay I mean if only you just
listened to my advice back in 2016 the
problem is that and you know we we love
you very much but a lot of Yousef
software recommendations
come from a like a niche Bean
mentality they come from a very dry
roasted Bean mentality I'm what you
would call an early adopter you are an
early adopter no you're the early
adopter early adop you early you you
early adopt everything which means some
of it some of it sticks and some of it
doesn't the reason it's called Bean is
instead of like Microsoft Word you used
software called Bean which do you still
use it no it was some really lightweight
open source text editor just just to
check have you got YouTube premium yet I
don't need it so no no no what was what
was the question that I asked no have
you still got the Argentinian version
for like 70p a month or something
correct through a VPN um but that's
that's it you spend how much money per
year on YouTube ads can we just say the
Argentinian YouTube premium let's just
not let's not skim over that because
because that is beaming if I ever saw
one that is Syrian dry
roasted don't you worry Habibi Habibi
it's okay so all that is to say that
when when youf
says I've got this bit of software I
think it's good you just let it you let
it simmer for at least 90 days and then
ask him again um tick tick is one of
those things it's a calendar to-do list
habit tracker anything else Pomodoro
Timer pomodora timer does slats all
these sorts of things but the thing it's
given me is which is a little
bit going against Yousef and I have had
a debate a long time about how you treat
the calendar youf put all of his tasks
in his calendar and I just put events in
my calendar and then deletes them and
then deletes them or defers
them
but I I recommended om Focus to you five
years ago four years and you've been
using it since I've been locked in I've
been grandfathered in I even took Peter
Aki's course on it and then brought
Peter rakis on the
show separately you know what I respect
about you Chris is that like when you
say okay I'm going to take on this
recommendation you really yeah you you
are one of the least flaky men I've ever
met well you saw me doing uh Achilles
rehab when we first went to Dubai
maniacally doing been like here that
would have been here would make this is
where I was laid with my foot up
notoriously boring upset toy we went to
uh we went to Dubai and George is laid
by a pool like reading like like
throwing Munga quotes at me and I'm I'm
I'm over there doing 5-second decentric
like single-legged C raises when you did
the mill big three like used to used to
go to CrossFit thousands of hours
everyone else is doing the wad just in
the corner just thousands of hours I've
done bird dog and side plank and Migel
cup do you regret it not at all not at
all I now have a spine that that
functions that works um so the thing I
remember you saying to me like I'm doing
my weekly review and I hate it
and I just kept saying like just just
just do it Chris it's good for you tick
tick makes that easier okay so I
basically just every nothing the hack is
nothing leaves the inbox without a date
attached to it but it's not necessarily
a date you'll do the thing and then all
you have to do is look at the today view
on tic tick and you go down at the start
of the day I look at this a batched box
at the top I either drag it to a time
slot I'm going to do it that day or I
review it cancel it delete it delegate
it do you have group view on Tik Tok
tick tick can you send it to like each
other can email things to his inbox and
he can email things to my inbox you
can't view each other's have shared
lists right okay that's pretty good so
if you're working on a project together
you could delegate tasks yousef's
convulsing can you see it yeah yeah he's
just got so much to say a shared list
well yeah but you you you're a good
example of separating planning from
execution so you have the planning time
and then you turn up on the day and you
just work through it's something I
changed my mind on this year big time I
thought it was terrible tried it didn't
like it got rid of it went back to omn
focus but you just then move to things
three don't perod I've tried everything
it's like it's like whoop I've tried the
whole but the gamut don't forget don't
forget I was about to switch to things
three I'm so I made of you I'm on such
satellite Delay from you I'm Douglas
Murray in the Gaza Strip like waiting
for Piers Morgan like we've just got got
packet loss haven't we yes yes thanks
Piers I've got you like that's me in a
[__] FL Jack tick tick right I want
you you've both promised me that one of
you will sit down and and transfer
different flows I've got a full guide on
YouTube that already watched it I've
already watched watched it already
watched the full thing ahead of the
curve of course well I wanted to get the
best in before you sit down and
personally coach me through it and I
feel like to be honest I feel like it
should be you because you cursed me with
three years of the most advanced task
manager pun in history yeah it is it's
just like recompense you know what I
mean you're right I I I put you right in
the deep end they have just launched the
new omn Focus what's this they've just
launched a new one I don't care it's
quite interesting with like social
networks or apps that are bad for you
they quite quickly get aote like there's
Instagram Facebook oh he's gone there we
go he's gone he's bailed out right well
if you you have to be at least partly
christmased so there you go um you have
like Instagram Tik Tok Facebook YouTube
and only recently has Tik Tok really
come along but with productivity apps
there's
so it's so such decentralization and so
much churn from product to product
people leave but I do like what you said
then about the life act I do think you
that's the problem I often have with
life ax is if a friend has just started
one you need that cooling off period
because that's the time when going to be
the loudest but if they come back in 90
that's the meta life hack today which is
wait at least 90 days for all life I
sent you that thing the other day that
was Paul Bloom quote quote tweeting
someone else where it was like um uh
I've just learned about the recency bias
and I have to say out of all of them
it's my
favorite very good so yeah when someone
says something to you set a reminder in
tick tick there we go 90 days all right
Seth you're up so the most enduring life
hack you guys will be no stranger to
this but I feel like since we've this is
a a new audience seeing this it's got to
be Alfred oh wow yeah okay so Alfred is
one of the OG life hacks and I have got
to be one of the heaviest user users so
I've checked my stats I've used it
400,000
times 400 times a day 400 times a day I
invoke Alfred 400 times a day it is inv
like it it is him it's a $20 piece of
software like Spotlight that genuinely I
would pay four figures for happily
happily happily Pig five probably if if
got morgage on his
Alfred I've got to pay for it on clana
that's they could have me over a barrel
so Alfred Developers please don't I
remember when you changed laptops you
said the thing you were most concerned
about changing Al Al preferences yeah
like it is a bastard I had to go through
it with you it feels like walking
through trial using a computer that
doesn't have Alfred and I've worked in
the NHS and that's like so I come from a
conversion rate optimization background
um okay so Alfred is the hack let's say
that no one people that are listening
don't know so they describe it as
Spotlight on steroids so it's a what
Spotlight Spotlight is the little
magnifying glass button on your keyboard
on your Comm space if you're watching
this on command space opens up any web
page or file or app or whatever but
Alfred has a load of extensibility as
well so you can I can control all of my
lights my Bluetooth um clipboard history
paste in uh text expansion so if you
start typing your mobile number text
that you often send quite a lot like
Hello thank you for your inquiry blah
blah blah best wishes
all that kind of stuff you just have it
at the tip of your fingers and it is
saved what do you use the most the
clipboard history same that's that was
what that's the card manager anyone that
doesn't have a clipboard manager that
spends a modum amount any more time on
their MacBook or the laptop it's MacBook
only as well isn't it it's so racist I
love it so bigoted I I love that though
as well because it's like if you're
using a Windows computer you've got
bigger problems yeah let me learn you
let me learn you about this
um the clipboard manager is insane so
for the most part you can only copy the
last thing that you can only paste the
last thing you copied whereas this is
you can set it up to basically Infinity
but it's like I think for me it's the
last 300 or 500 or something things
which means that you can go through a
document or a web page and find all of
the different things that you need to
copy and then go onto where you need to
paste them and paste all of the
different things that you need to paste
full clipboard manager uh you can even
do conditional formatting when it comes
to the Snippets which is their expansion
so I have an invite message my invite
for the podcast has got progressively
shorter now it's hi there can you direct
me to whoever handles your podcast
invites please thanks uh and that's in
invvy 3 in invvy 2 is when I need to
show a little bit more uh how would you
say like reputational ankle like a sort
of there's a little bit uh and then skin
iv1 is I haven't updated that in Forever
is that short shorts no it's huge that's
oh yeah yeah it is cool that's only fans
only fans free member
access um very nice yeah so I've got a
full guide on that as well that kind of
to walk through but just start playing
around with it and you'll figure out so
many you get free trial period I think
with omn focus with with uh there's a
free version but then the real juice
comes from the $20 it's $20 once off
like power pack five figures for that
100% the Delta of price to I think it's
You' pay five figures for use of set up
yeah I think our setup's probably worth
in the like high four figure range yeah
ethereum uh all right what have I got
next
uh right I'll go for this one um I'm
pretty certain that hold luggage is a
scop meant to keep you poor and late wow
I am yet to find a scenario in which
hand luggage isn't sufficient now you
need to get good luggage that's a huge
mediator of this but I was on tour me
and James Smith I did 29 days on the
road just hand luggage wow no waiting
ever for luggage to come out the other
end it's always with you at all times uh
and it causes you to be a little bit
more thoughtful with what it is that
you're packing which is important
because what you find is if you've got
like dude hold luggage is massive 23
kilos unless you carrying a ton of
conditioner and shampoo I was going to
say where'd you put your
treasure your salon grade shampoo we
once went liquid is there we once went
to Iceland not the supermarket the
country we once drove to Edinburgh while
Yousef had
menitis to fly to Iceland and I tried to
transport five kilos of Tres uh because
I just hadn't thought I hadn't thought
to deant it into something smaller wow
you managed to sweet talk The glaswegian
person at the desk he'll do that to
transport liquids as well mindblowing
sweet talk glaswegians into worse into a
national security threat for Iceland
yeah too much
Tres what is this that you brought with
you um so cheapest thing there it was
the cheapest thing there but yeah um
hold luggage is a scop meant to keep you
poor and late and you can get away with
hand luggage only quite easily I have a
lot of questions hit me
liquids uh get travel size containers
and do you run out do you buy more when
you drop up to 100 up to 100 Mil no so I
will caveat this there's a couple of
complications first one is going to be
if you use spray
anti-perspirant very difficult to five a
75 mil of that very difficult lots of
105 Ms which is [__] infuriating um
don't use a roll on not a massive fan of
a rollon would rather go for a spray
that's that's a challenge yes liquids
but you buy an anti person one you when
you when you arrive somewhere if it
depends how many stops you're doing if
this is one trip yes if it's multiple
trips no cuz that's just you that's
intermittent intermittent purchasing so
you can get you know like 25 mil spray
thing and just get like three or four or
five of them and just throw them in and
you you must be doing like you must be
washing your clothes regular I did I did
laundry while I was there but I don't
know about you
I the uh how would you say like Overton
window of acceptable clothing to me
isn't that broad I don't have much more
than about a hold luggage worth of
clothes that are like nice and cool to
me at anyone time so for me to cycle
through that stuff I would probably be
doing it anyway and I would just have
random Surplus pieces of clothing that
wouldn't get W cuz I'm like don't like
that t-shirt like I really love that
t-shirt though so I'll get that one
washed and I'll do it again so i'
probably do that even if I was in hold
luggage mode and then what is the what
is the hand luggage
recommendation so before I started
spending any amount of money on luggage
I would have said luggage is luggage
it's [__] pointless it's like why are
you even trying to do it then I upgraded
and got an away away which is pretty
good uh and that has sort of tie down
straps that make things like much more
organized and then I started using
nomatic before I was a partner with them
so I bought their stuff and then became
a partner with them and it's just
magical like different sections magnetic
ties so that you can lock things down
and push things down different sections
for everything they have a it's called a
you got you got the backpack what's your
backpack called travel
pack they've got two one's a travel pack
and the other's a uh I can't [__]
can't remember it'll be I'll link it in
the show notes below um but it's just
it's this backpack opens like clamshell
from both sides and it's just phenomenal
so nomatic website just has all of the
stuff on there and it it's really good
but it just changes it changes the
quality of your life having genuine high
quality luggage even if you are going to
go hold luggage like there's ways that
you can like lift different things up
and oh man it's [__] it's outstanding
wow can it fit a spare du James James
Smith managed to fit uh a pillow with
him because he travels with his own
pillow what pregnancy pillow no uh like
normal head pillow he's bailed out of
the pregnancy pillow life too hot a lot
of people uh flying Long Haul had
brought their own pillows I noticed that
I feel like that's probably going to be
a future if I was to predict what my
life hack next J is going to be I reckon
taking a pillow with you while you
travel is it Blow pillow or no he fits
out in his luggage fits in hand luggage
bro in hand luggage thin pillow if it's
a thin pillow it's squish all what you
want is it squash down anyway that's my
that's my thing hold luggage bail out of
it get good hand luggage and backpack
and roller and you'll be able to get
away with it also one final one if you
are traveling and really struggling for
space whether it be hand luggage or hold
luggage if you want to just have like
let's say shoes shoes take up quite a
bit of room aren't that heavy and you
usually don't have space for them just
go into the airport go to wh Smiths or
something like that buy a bottle of
water put your shoes in the bag no one
ever complains about you taking retail
on from within the
airport where were the shoes before is
this before you go through security yeah
yeah so like literally just so you're
walking into the airport holding loads
of shoes carrying shoes yeah buy a
bottle of water ask for a bag yep put it
in the bag because if they didn't allow
you on with stuff that you purchased
from wh Smiths or wh Smith wouldn't
operate in there
go [__] yourself
airports damn hack um so my one um again
it's one I've done for a while so I put
it it's beenin it's not fresh this week
so it's been through the filter um past
the 90day filter pretty much I would be
surprised everyone who's listened to you
as well as YouTube in the fitness scene
they've tracked like their lifts they've
tracked their nutrition they've tracked
sleep over the years but very very few
people have ever tracked like their
mental health or mood
so I created this idea which I realized
is quite a big therapeutic technique
which didn't realize at the time but
essentially imagine you have your mood
so you have zero here which is worst day
of your life and then like 10 here
ecstasy pill in the system serotonin
like maxing off the charts and let's say
you kind of each days varies between a
four to a six and maybe not a British
four or a six cuz a British person like
their worst days are four and their best
days are six but um a a wider ranging
one so let's say you have a to a six
every single day as soon as you go
outside of that so if you go sub four
for whatever reason just have a little
like apple note table like negative mood
here positive mood there just drop in
the date and what the cause was and
likewise if you go above a six just
write down oh um great morning uh slept
eight hours coffee's in the system deep
works whatever it is that's caused it
write it down two dues um write it down
and then at the end of the year you have
like 70 different entries or even at the
end of the month you'll have like five
or six different entries that you can
just be like oh okay this thing shown up
multiple times and it's one thing to
have like a bad hangover and say I'm not
going to drink again but you then forget
comes Saturday but then let's say you
look at the data and you go hold on 83%
of my bad moods that were enough to
register in this table like was alcohol
and you can you can put it in a little
Google sheet and just see that that
thing there that hits so much harder and
likewise with the Positive moods as well
it's basically whoop for mindset isn't
it for mood can I add a couple of things
to that George so I love that idea um
this is the new Apple there's my abysmal
step count as well, 1200 steps um busy
morning but slightly Pleasant or
slightly unpleasant day for example so I
think this is the journal or is one of
the recent updates having slightly
pleasant day so this is part of the new
iOS they have a a mood tracker with tags
so you can do that natively within Apple
Health but also for something that's
more sophisticated you can use
exist. oh that's it log a mood can we
show the can we show that to the
camera neutral if I do this oh it's
unpleasant go this way oh slightly
pleasant but the reason that I still
prefer exist doio it's about $7 a month
or something is that you can pass the
data and do a lot of good stuff with it
and figure out what doesn't sound like
you it it'll put yeah it'll export to a
CSV oh lovely and it'll you it pulls out
correlations some of them might be a bit
spurious like on on days that it rains
you have sex more or something but I
suppose that's that probably you see
that thing about the uh the correlation
between the number of Nicholas Cage
films released in a year and the number
of people who dry from uh die from
drowning in swimming pools it's like a
really strong
correlation yeah I don't know how some
in ice cream and ice cream cells and
murders isn't it is the standup one so
have you learned anything from those
correlations yeah so I I do it for a lot
of the tests that we do so when I'm
testing out red light therapy or um
vagal tone methods or anything like that
I'll use exist to track what are the
effects on different aspects of your
life oh and it connects with your whoop
and your Apple health and everything
well you made a custom private web page
that exports to a Google
sheet uh so you may between apple health
and exist iio you may have found a a way
to do this there's a there's a simpler
one which is just inside timer have you
seen that yeah they ask you how you're
feeling and you can there's like five
faces like very sad but you need to be
able to have why are you feeling that
way but you need to have it in metrics
and then you need to be able to track
Trends you do I've tried the um all the
custom Solutions but I come back to
again midw like the Apple notes gole
sheets table and because I can then
write I can get quite specific about
what the thing was that day and then the
ability to reflect back on that 6 months
and go oh that then triggers the memory
of that day and I can go into a lot more
detail versus if it's just purely a
score and a tag it doesn't ring the same
because sometimes it'll be like a l ofer
effect as well it'll be three or four
things imagine if you had it all
connected where it says when you tweet
more frequently your heart rate is
higher and then you're like ah okay so
that's pulling like whoop data it pulls
everything in like it connects so
much that's either really helpful or
like really upsetting isn't it well it
again I think it's about identifying the
trends and then letting go of the
tracking whatever it yeah right Johnny
you're up lesson lesson lesson is uh
looking at things in 10year Windows so
we as youf mentioned we' gone from two
to 19 employees and the natural
assumption would be what did we do in
January to make that happen I actually
think it's a decade of work that made
that happen and so the lesson is if you
assume that if you just take enough
swings at whatever it is you're trying
to achieve you'll eventually get there
and it will likely take a lot longer
than you think how focusing on how you
can just be comfortable with the mundane
repetitive nature of it and it you
mentioned this in your talk about how
well when we were out here you were
doing these episodes and no one was
listening so there was no reward there
was no well it was a little bit like the
episodes were growing I guess but
there's a lot of repetition without much
success and then this year vertical so
if it's going to take another 10 years
how do you make what you're doing now
enjoyable detaching from the outcome
homo's got uh a bit about this where he
says uh disciplined people aren't more
patient they just find something to do
in the
meantime yeah yeah it's like just find
something to do in the meantime if you
assume that it's going to take a long
time to achieve the thing that it is
that you want to do and presume that
it's going to take twice as long as you
want it to take or that you
realistically think it could take how
could you make it bearable that between
now and then life just ticks over so
there's two two quotes that are like one
of them is a chural quote supposedly
we'll never know the other one is a Gary
Gary ve concept the Gary ve concept is
being very patient macro but impatient
micro so like allow something to take 10
years but be very impatient this week
today this hour whatever um then the
Churchill thing is success is going from
Fairly fairly to fairly without loss of
enthusiasm which I think is really not
to say we're a success but I think the
success for us has happened because we
just didn't lose enthusiasm but you also
it wasn't like you had a lots of
failures there wasn't a point where you
guys were close to bankruptcy or
anything like that I think beh behind
the scenes lots of failures lots of
things that we tried munde boring
failure which were actually in some ways
even even worse suppose you only lock in
a failure when you all
right whereas we just ran into lot lots
of like just little nudges like head
against the wall like really trying
tried this thing and it didn't work you
tried this thing but this is I talk
about this in the live show the like
unspectacular failures and how common
they are right that like tarnish your
entire experience of whatever it is that
you're doing because you hear uh Rocky
cutscene montage and he can't lift a log
and then he goes back and he still can't
lift a log and he goes back and he still
can't and then he does lift a log and
you're like oh all of those things with
that and yours is like you're not even
trying to lift a log you're just trying
to get your Alfred shortcuts to work
right or you're trying to send an
invoice through quickbox and it just
doesn't want to work you're like like
it's you know what I
mean that with no easy way
out no easy way out just resending
[__] QuickBooks invoices Ivan Drago's
got all the Alfred shortcuts yeah yeah
yeah it's better touch tool is
completely optimized
three
Duos
three but yeah I think so the lessons
just um assume it's going to take you
longer than you think and then focusing
on like how do I make myself okay with
that CU I think everyone wants the
there's a lot of focus on especially in
our world in building building business
world where everyone wants it now and if
you said to those people like okay it's
going to take 10 years how are you going
to make yourself comfortable with that
it's it's trying to accept that and come
up with a strategy where you still enjoy
it finding something to do in the
meantime I guess you gave me instant
nausea when you mentioned that earlier
if it's the idea of you mentioned this
you get to the top of the ladder and you
realize the ladder's against against the
wrong wall right yeah how so with the
10e are you now planning out things on a
10year Time horizon or how is it kind of
tactically Chang it's just looking
rather than thinking like what's the
goal this month this year think like
okay whatever we we need to keep doing
what whatever we're doing for longer
than we're planning to do MH H instead
of setting up something that feels
unsustainable how do I make it feel
sustainable so emergent success is
something that I've been thinking about
a lot it's weird like jocker willink
said this before we started the podcast
I don't even think that we were
recording when he said this but he said
um I asked him about plans long-term
plans or it might be in the episode I
can't remember and uh he said 5 years
ago I'd never written a book hadn't
launched a supplement company didn't
have a podcast and was basically a grunt
out of the army if I'd had any plan all
of the optionality and exponential
success just blew it out of the water so
I think having long-term plans might
work for some people in relatively
predictable uh Industries or or sort of
predictable processes but for me I've
almost largely dispensed with plans that
are longer than a year it's like I can
guess where we're going to be over the
next 12 months is but most of it's just
emerence so for either of you so we had
a we had a business go at the start of
the year we we met that in the first
quarter how did how have your business
the best kind yeah but so like so the
the plan pointless one of one of our the
a guy who used to coach me for
powerlifting shifted Mike tar yeah I'm
not Pock no but you so he he shifted
like long complicated periodization to
just why don't we just write a week of
training and then we'll just do that
week of training until it stops working
planning out a year gives or five years
gives people a sense of control but it's
completely but you're still you're still
just reacting to circumstances things
Chang I think it's so dependent on the
industry you're in so like being a
doctor I imagine it's quite an easy
thing to do a 5year plan oh yeah because
the whole path is laid out it's very I
want to become a neuros a pediatric
neuros you probably got a 15year plan
just laid out for you there but
particularly entrepreneurship or
something that's very Dynamic and kind
of related to technology that's
constantly changing exponentials are
just going to throw your [__] throw your
[__] out of the water there's no way
that you're going to be able to hold on
CU all of the there
are things and opportunities that are
going to be laid in front of you that
you literally don't even know exist
right now you know you're if you're
trying to be a neurosurgeon pediatric
neurosurgeon there isn't going to be
some area of pediatric neurosurgey that
you're as yet unaware of that's going to
be able to be achieved within the space
of six months but if it's anything with
a ton of optionality in all of this [__]
Could Happen
immediately Europe up Seth
I've been seeing a therapist
for just under two years now and it's
been a fantastic decision so I think
there's a lot
of resistance that people have to doing
that because there's kind of an implicit
assumption that if you see a therapist
that you're somehow broken or
traumatized and I think that keeps a lot
of people away from growing and you you
know and it's become I've noticed it's
become rebranded a lot in the corporate
world as like performance coaching or
whatever but it's just it is just
therapy just rebranded under a new name
what it basically is and a true
therapist is actually just a mirror to
you so that they don't really they're
not forthcoming with advice they're not
they don't kind of nudge you too much
you turn up and they just hold up the
mirror and show you how much of a [__]
you're being in your daily decisions and
I very much think it's like turbo
journaling the difference is when you
Journal you are writing within your own
Echo chamber and your Journal doesn't
call you out for being a [__] whereas a
therapist will call you out on your
[__] so that's been really valuable
and I would very much recommend like for
the sake of 50 to 100 quid per session
well worth it I've been in therapy as
well uh in Austin so I I found a friend
who did an awful lot of therapy for a
very long time and is superbly [__] up
and I figured if his therapist can deal
with him she can definitely deal with me
it's like I'm way less messed up than he
is at least that's what I thought and uh
it's been it's been really really great
and yeah the uh mirror thing what ends
up
happening a lot of time you spent just
thinking about your childhood and you
just don't give yourself the room any
even marginally busy person just doesn't
have the room to think about like that
conversation you once had with your
history teacher um I had Dr Paul Cony on
the show did that four episode series
with huberman a few months ago uh
unconscious mind trauma all that stuff
Fu dude I'm living in Austin Texas so
the concept of people being sat in a
sauna whining on about their ancestral
trauma or like about how this thing from
before affected them and all the rest of
it has really kind of put the wibbles up
me about just not wanting to like yeah
all right mate like jog on like this
isn't the goggin's Joo pilled side of me
just doesn't want to hear it um but Dr
Paul con's reframed my perspective on
that that there are things that you
don't think about that are part of your
unconscious programming that your body
takes completely for granted and just
sort of grandfathers in as part of the
landscape or the texture of your mind to
the way that you see the world it's just
this unconscious assumption that you
take as truth or fact and it's not and
it wasn't before you had it and you've
whitewashed your entire life to believe
that this is the way it's always been
and it isn't and that shapes all of your
micro decisions and the filter that you
see the world and all of that as you say
because of one way that you chose to
interpret something early on so I guess
the I'd see journaling ration therapy
they're all on the same Spectrum it's
just that one of them's kind of assisted
like it's almost like you're you're
using steroids to journal and you're
getting more out of it it's like a like
a forced guided prompted journaling yeah
exactly the questions that prompt the
like oh I hadn't thought about that
before and there's that like external
accountability isn't there like you you
you then cuz you can choose not to
journal one day or you can choose not to
write stuff out in depth but if someone
tell me more about that so on that note
and I guess this comes around to what
you what you're saying
before I Consolidated about 12 years of
journals so from day one I was a lot
more I used day one a lot more heavily
than you did by the sound of it and I
went through it took me two or 3 months
of a lot of time every day to
consolidate all of the lessons and
journal entries and everything turn them
into a visual map identify the emergent
themes this was before chat GPT could
have done this at minutes I know it
could have but actually I think doing it
manually was quite useful it's like
revising yeah you don't need someone
else to summarize your notes for you you
need to summize your not so I and I
mapped it out and it was phenomenal to
see it just laid out in a very big
spatial categorized way of like okay
this is is what 12 years of journaling
has taught me and the ridiculous thing
about it is that 21-year-old you knows
all the stuff that you need to be doing
now but you just keep cycling through
those same lessons and it's like 21 year
old version of you is shouting like just
do this thing and then a couple of weeks
later you go oh you've had like the
child birth Amnesia about it and you go
that's fine and then it keeps coming
back around and I think until you
integrate and do those lessons the same
thing is going to keep bouncing back
into your Consciousness until you assess
it one of the worst things to realize we
often get
asked all of us will uh what do you what
would you 10 years ago wish that you'd
know and that you know now and you look
back and you think oh oh you know
there's this and this and this and this
is the way I see the world and these are
one of my patterns almost always those
things when I answer those questions are
still things that me in 10 years time
will be wishing that me right now and
knew it's midwit once again we're
looking for the the higher optimization
the next oh this is more nuanced no no
no I'm more sophisticated in that it's
like no no no no you are still you and
your patterns are still your patterns
and maybe this is where the unconscious
work comes in maybe some of the you know
Dr Paul conty style like unveiling the
unconscious would break that and you
might genuinely have new or novel
challenges that you need to change but
given the fact that you are still you
the things that you're that you were
fighting with 10 years ago are almost
certainly the same things you're
fighting with now when did we do the
things you would tell your 18-year-old
self podcast oh [__] hell I bet we
should we should we go back and listen
to that just almost certainly it'll be
the same [__] I think it was by Bitcoin
to do 531 it was by Bitcoin do 531 that
was it buy Bitcoin do 531 maybe not the
worst advice if you had in fact if you
had If You Can Count 531 as a single
word that would be four words that you
could just like text your last self buy
Bitcoin do 531 I found a tool when I was
like 18 that you can email yourself in
10 years time future me.or yeah
something like that and I got the email
the other day and it was like hi it's
youf I'm 18 years old yeah it what did
he say by still you still you
still you were still Muslim then yeah
very deep deep the Muslim Go De did you
reply I might have actually I might have
set one for another 10 years um honestly
I can't remember what I said but it was
really it was quite emotional to see I
sent one to myself in a year a couple of
months ago nice looking forward to
getting it all right wait are we on
lessons we are on lessons aren't we yeah
we are on lessons all right so this is
uh technically one from last year and it
was inspired by a conversation I had
with Jake
Humphries uh he said these are the
golden years you can't wait until you've
got no stress or worry in your life
before you decide to be happy because
guess what you will always have stress
and worry and anxiety and problems and
issues to deal with so you have to
decide now that happiness is something
you're going to have and it's that
little throwaway line at the beginning
which I use as a mantra these are the
golden years it's a great
hertica time when you have no problems
what did you think that one day you're
just going to wake up and cease having
problems like completing a video game
and leveling up to a map where there's
nothing there that's never going to
happen your problems will change but
having problems is going nowhere
whatever negativity is consuming your
thoughts probably won't matter in 3
months time in 3 months you won't
remember the negative texture of your
mind or the boring repetitive things you
thought or maybe even what you were
worried about but the time that you
spent worrying will have passed so
you're sacrificing your joy and presence
in the moment for a problem which you
won't even be able to recall in the
future immortality would be the only
life in which such flippancy with the
days that you live for is
acceptable in your talk you say
everybody has this Mantra of after this
week things will calm down it's the diet
starts Monday and Naval talks about that
as like you assume that because your
calendar has Whit space in three month's
time that oh I'm going to be full of um
excitement and willingness to just book
in coffees with all these people that I
haven't been doing for a long time and
I'll I'll be able to start these new
hobbies and start fishing and I'll be of
jubilance and willingness to try try new
things it's like no it's just you
haven't filled up your calendar yet with
the normal mundane stuff so from a time
management perspective and from a
happiness perspective that's been a real
yeah if you wouldn't say yes to this
proposed meeting for tomorrow don't say
yes to it for three months time it'll be
exactly the same it's going to be the
exact same yeah you just have to presume
that things are going to remain the same
in terms of workload and uh yeah I think
just these are the golden years as like
don't and and you know this is kind of I
guess a little bit of a counter to some
of the more Goggins Joo hosy pilled like
homos maxing philosophies which are you
know you can grit your teeth and and and
now is the time to like go to war and
like all of that stuff but so many of
the best outcomes that we've all got in
life is when we found the intersection
of something which is valuable and that
we enjoy to do because it makes
everything easy and in the meantime
that's actually going to be fun like
what's the [__] point yes like if
you're going to sacrifice your enjoyment
in the moment for success in the future
so that when you finally have enough
success in the future you can enjoy
yourself it's like you the bar stool's
upside down given that most of all
destination Acquisitions can constitute
Journeys like optimized for the journey
not the destination the hosy thing of
the I think he calls it the grandfather
frame have you heard that one you
haven't heard that one it depends what
it is what on Earth so it was it's like
a 10-minute YouTube video he has and I
listened to it
um while like while on holiday actually
and he talks about how he tries to look
at life now how 80-year-old him would
see currently and you suddenly get an
appreciation for like I can like get up
and go to the kitchen and like my back
doesn't hurt my knees don't hurt I don't
have arthritis spending time with my
wife who just got married like this is
what a like beautiful time of life you
like look at now and look at it focuses
the things on focuses his attention on
things that you take for granted but in
when you're 80 won't be there anymore
and I think that's like a everyone talks
about like feel gratitude and keep like
write down things you're grateful for
each morning but that that single video
was the biggest of like oh [__] yeah
like all this stuff like I had to spend
time doing a podcast when I'm 80 I'll be
sat there and on my own like looking
back on now thinking God that was so
good so much fun yeah these are these
are the golden years I think it's just
such a good such a good reframe just
assume that now is the best that your
life is ever going to be and in
retrospect you're going to wish that you
could be back here now it's that whole
when I was 20 I wanted to be a
millionaire now I'm a millionaire I just
want to be
20 yeah it's like what Warren Buffett
is Rich but he would trade places with
every like 18-year-old mhm yeah time
billionaires is what they call it it's
hard to make a profound statement with
his glasses on it really really you'd be
surprised I really think it works all
right you're up so um one of my favorite
ones from this year which I think by
definition it won't change because it's
the Jeff Bezos ISM of asking what's not
going to change everyone's obsessed with
oh like what's going to happen with AI
and what's going to happen in this
industry what how are things going to
change got to take this off um but few
people ask what's not going to change so
he uses it for Amazon where it's like oh
is this Tech going to comeing is this
competitor going to come in he goes all
that could happen but even the smartest
people throughout history have a very
very difficult time predicting the
future but if he goes well what's not
going to change he like creates this
fake scenario of no customer is going to
say can I have uh slower delivery times
can it cost more can you have fewer
choices available on Amazon and okay
okay those are the things to focus on
and looking at every industry or every
sector that you give a piss about really
and just saying what isn't going to
change and then just focusing on those
it's the bloker the electrical Tower or
the telecoms tower who's just got the
lever like he's not going anywhere
unless electricity gets subverted by a
new
thing that's not going to change 100%
even like for the the podcast right you
could there's loads of new things that
you can try with Spotify and YouTube and
things like that but what is not going
to change 10 years from now people want
to listen to a combination of guests
that they they already know and love
people that they never heard of and
topics that they are interested in now
topics that they didn't know that they
were interested in in the future and
they want to listen to it in an
acceptable quality of audio and video
like that's podcasting in a nutshell uh
so yeah optimizing for those things and
is the point of that to get distracted
less yes to focus on the few things that
matter okay so you put your attention on
the the core stuff and like let the
changes and the the technology or
whatever come and go I mean you can
still play around with the Technologies
you can still do that but when people
get so caught up like for example if he
was getting so caught up in a new
technology but then the delivery speed
was getting slower and slower or people
were getting faster or the prices were
getting higher and higher it's reminding
of oh there's there's an infinite
dashboard of metrics for me to focus on
here what are the ones I should focus on
he lives that as well like he's now just
building infrastructure on
infrastructure isn't he like
multigenerational this is Amazon web
systems and now he's moving on to
bigger things from the The Lex episode
yeah right Johnny you're up hack hack
this is a recent one one I told you
about recently opal phone app for it as
well enjoying it I'm careful about my
recency bias I've only been with it for
like I'm in the 90day window so ignore
this okay well or yeah ignore this um no
but it's it kind of uh of all the I've
tried a lot of different like screen
time iPhone app blocking stuff I think
this one makes it the simplest yeah
agreed um and it's cool how you can have
like your friends on there I think
that's the best thing about it so you
can there's just like a it kind of TAPS
into the like I quite like to be top of
the leaderboard I saw that you did 4
hours and 15 minutes the other day
immediately thought I've got an extra
three hours today
yeah yeah did you get one hour something
like 1 hour 20 yeah a couple of times
you see you see I saw that and I was
like I feel like I do okay with my phone
saw that and I was like God like I've
got it's pretty robust so yeah opal time
blocking and they have like preset
things like um so I have like an
automated one which is like 7:00 a.m.
till midday is like deep work and then
there's one which is like they do a
lunchtime one they do like a last hour
of the day one I've custom put mine
together it's pretty easy to do I think
I've seen that in action your status
changing on iMessage right does it stat
it to do not disturb you want do not
disturb I don't think so no I think
that's a separate thing oh I wonder if
you could create a shortcut
so that when your when opal triggers a
focus block put you in Focus mode it
automatically puts you in do not disturb
I think just making the screen screen
time's hard right like it's hard to use
a phone properly or like without getting
distracted so turning it into a game
making it competitive I want to beat
Chris how do I beat Chris like you you
start thinking like I could leave my
phone I mean my screen time's getting
trashed at the minute but I could leave
my phone away during this part of the
day I could not have it with me then
like I I struggle to think how I'm going
to beat you to be honest it's impressive
I'm bad I'm bad don't worry did you just
have like a good day give me time yeah
I've had a couple of good days but it's
also like new app Effectiveness
something new's come in that's just
obliterated my ability to do stuff and I
haven't yet found the work I'll get I'll
get you over like a 60-day period
probably almost certainly yeah as of yet
my you know like the path of a river
it's like oh we're going to divert it
around this way your yeah just roads EX
so I'm going to burst the bank
eventually but right now I'm in this
beautiful Goldie Lock Zone it gives you
Little Gems each day as well have you
noticed I've got loads yeah I've got go
look how excited we are about not using
our phone opal good good Pro Europe R
and Doris who I think you met a few
weeks ago y has changed the way that I
structure my day with the six alarms
principle so I set multiple alarms
throughout the day this sounds so stupid
saying it aloud but we we've realized
over the last few years that you have to
treat yourself like like a child to be
able to get anything done and I now set
alarms at midday just before shutdown at
shutdown and then a like bedtime routine
so what they do is just create this kind
of bookend or like a a wall in the day
where it's like okay this block of time
is now over you're into the next phase
you're into the next phase and it stops
me from just kind of running on and just
working late or ignoring my own
arbitrary boundaries and I think when
you're self-employed that becomes so
important especially shifting from what
we've done which is going from full-time
employment with a clear clock on and
clock off into an office or into a
hospital and then it's like the time is
very clearly defined for you but
suddenly when you're self-employed
There's No Boundaries on your time and
you could just if you if you have the
disposition like us you would just work
infinitely and end up working late and
then stealing time from yourself because
then you wake up late the next day and
you're tired and then you work worse
that day and you have to catch up and
then so it just avoids all of that with
a simple alarm so why do you have six I
actually have four uh ran says you can
he he says you can pick a number that's
not not so many that it divides the day
into like a ridiculous number of blocks
but I think it's important just to pick
time time blocks that make sense for you
based on when you want to start working
when you want to stop and work backwards
from there so you start start at the end
of your day and then a lot arms to like
bookmark that of like where should I be
yeah and it stops you from then just
being like oh I've got quite a bit to do
today I'll just work a bit later cuz
it's like oh no there is a hard deadline
to the day now so it forces you to then
filter things more aggressively and do
everything gets Parkinson's Lord yeah
yeah that's nice his anti- morning
morning routine as well of just start
writing within 90 seconds of opening
your eyes is I do that I've been
doing it's really good yeah this book
that it looks like I'm going to be
writing press
fless uh yeah I I like to I like to
switch between Theta and Delta as much
as I can yeah um what am I going to go
for all right [__] it um sleep token is
my next life hack oo that their album
they're a band I guess halfway between
that technically referred to now as [__]
metal [__] metal [__] metal it's like
metal that you'd have sex with so like
them
um oh wow it's called [__] metal uh
anyway so sleep token are a band that
have been around for quite a while they
managed to do at the start of this year
five tracks released from their album
each one of them made it onto spotify's
most trending page each release like
every fortnite for three months or
something as a metal band but calling
them a metal band probably does them a
disservice it's got kind of jazz in
there it's got rap it's got R&B and it
is I would say the most complete
complete album take me back to Eden is
the most complete album that I've ever
heard in my entire life and it's just
they're phenomenal and I was listening
to them in the gym earlier on thinking
about life hacks for today and I
realized across the last year they're
all my top five songs from Spotify
wrapped are all by on that album they're
all by sleep talking they all from take
me back to Eden and listening to music
that just makes you so happy and is
useful for uplifting your mood making
you train harder getting you into a good
State just that so sleep token take me
back to Eden [__] I'm up there you
sent that album to me and I dismissed it
twice so I think it takes a couple of
times oh you give it a crack and then
bailed out and give it a crack did you
listen to it in full yeah did you really
yeah just I think I was expecting
something very different yeah um very
different it's [__] brilliant but
yeah so it's very very good strong very
good G um my one so uh yeah this is one
that everybody knows about but not to
the level I think I'm going to suggest
so me and uh chat gbt have developed
quite an interesting relationship to say
the least but basically um what chat gbt
is unlocked which I don't think most
people have realized yet is you can
basically go to like level one of every
single video game so what I mean by that
is I won't lie there'll be things that
people would speak about who are a lot
smarter than me so people discuss the
laws of physics and they'd start talking
I'd be like nodding my head but I didn't
actually know what any of that meant or
like any kind of rudimentary concept
that I just zoned out at school and they
immediately it's like level 37 or it's
like they're talking about level sorry
season 12 episode 4 of friends at the
six minute Mark and I have no context of
who any of the characters are and the
ability to go into chat gbt chat gbt
isn't useful for any like Dynamic on the
edge topics so like if you were learning
Tik Tok ads it wouldn't be that great
for it but if you go on there I'll give
you two examples so like David deutch's
book the beginning of infinity read it
and it's quite dry I are probably just
below the IQ threshold where it would
like IQ Market fit for that book and
what I would do is I I prompt chat GPT
and I go okay um I want to know the 10
most important Concepts from this book
one by one and do not move on until I
say I understand and I would just sit
there it prints the first one and I go I
don't get that word there and I don't
get what you mean by that and then it
Sprint something else out and I go okay
explain like a smart 10-year-old d d d
and you get to the bottom of the
basement and you go ah I get it whereas
in the book he'll s you'll be getting it
getting it getting it and then they'll
say a concept that you don't fully
understand and then he moves on and then
that concept is like the um the
foundation for all these other stuff and
you just check out and the ability to
use chat GPT for any kind of
foundational topic and say with an
airpod you showed me the other day you
can use the audio version as well so you
can speak back and forth to it you can
you look at and you go I can understand
anything that nothing is too
intimidating if I use chat gbt correctly
so there's almost there's no such thing
as not knowing something is just not
prompting chat GPT to the level and the
personalization it can have cuz I think
that's the fundamental thing where the
education system breaks is um I think
Nal spoke about it but you'll be
understanding understanding
understanding then you're off one day
you come back in and you didn't get that
bit of algebra and they keep going on
and on and on but the ability to get any
bit of non-fiction foundational text
personalized to you and doesn't move on
until you understand it is absolutely
phenomenal passive with that I did a
math degree and if you if you zone out
for a couple of minutes in in a pure
math proof you are yeah you're
fine so the fact that you can the
airpods thing I think is massive that
you show like so chat GPT have now
introduced conversational AI so you can
have an airpod in go out for a walk and
talk to it about explain relativity to
me and I think the tonality that it uses
is frightening hey would you like to
know more about that it's the it sounds
so human doesn't it's only going to get
more and more human but the the thing
I'd say with this is for anybody
listeners any topic now that you're kind
of embarrassed to ask people about or
somebody says something that you don't
want to ask because you assume every
smart person knows that any topic you
just say explain the 10 most important
topics don't move on until I say I
understand and just keep asking why why
why explain like a 10-year-old and you
just realize you can understand any
topic if you leave it all in the same
have one big thread with all the stuff
you want to learn does it can it just
quicker more quickly get begins to learn
as well the fundamental problem is is
Google had a little bit of that but with
time Google's only got worse and worse
somebody said something recently um
where it's like if you Google what
disease you have you don't find out what
disease you have you just find out which
one has the best SEO and that's that's
that's the fundamental problem like
Google which is always the most serious
one Google as a product is getting worse
and worse every single year and chat GPT
is getting better and better it's just a
matter
of until it goes but it is so good for
personalized education particularly for
historical or foundational topics any
moment of History any book that's been
around for a long time so good or even
if you're on holiday somewhere and you
go I'm here tell me the 10 most
important things about this place it's
incredible that's strong all right we've
got about 10 minutes left should we do
one more round of hacks or one more
round of lessons what do you think I've
got a decent lesson a weak hack I'll do
lesson all right lessons it is
um I think this is originally from the
book 10,000 weeks by Oliver B Oliver
Bergman um defining something I struggle
with a lot defining done or defining a
productive day ahead of time so I had
this realization that I very rarely if
ever leave a training session with
unfinished exercises I finish the
exercises but I'm not in the gym for
like stupid amounts of time I've like
thought about it and I've like planned
myself a reasonable number of exercises
and I finish them but I almost always
endend a day with uncomplete tasks so I
like look at my all and then you you
finish the day
feeling unsatisfied unsatisfied um so
just slightly under egging it's as
simple as it is just slightly undering
how many things you're going to do in a
day so create your to-do list for like
hung over tired you because you can
always just borrow stuff from tomorrow
and if you let's say you do eight things
a day every day today you you plan to do
six and you borrow two from tomorrow you
feel mint when you finish the day but if
you plan to do 10 and you only do eight
you feel terrible there's a permanent
dissatisfaction I think that many people
especially me have with our to-do list
there are more things that you have to
do you have an infinite number of things
to do and even if you don't have an
infinite number of things to do you
definitely have an infinite number
almost an infinite number of more things
than you can do today which means that
there will permanently be I've it's not
it's like uh like bailing out it's like
and that's enough for now as opposed to
I am finished and that sense of I am
finished is a degree of satisfaction
that I think we should all be trying to
achieve more I have this res I have this
resistance to because I'm like oh well
but that means I'll do less stuff but I
won't I'll get to the end of the to-do
I'm like yeah do some other it's the
calendar whites space thinking oh well
I've got all this white space if I'm not
filling it all up back to back ramming
myself with tasks then I'm falling short
but actually if you do that and you have
no buffer time it just takes a poo
that's 2 minutes too long to completely
knock out your entire day speaking of
experience dude I remember this when I
snapped my achilles I had this very
precisely planned weekend so it was the
weekend that a bunch of new tenants were
moving into one of my houses and I
needed to get this new TV and drop it
off and all of the Ikea stuff that was
in the back of my car so that the guy
that would build it was going to be
there and he was going to be there the
next day but the TV needed to be
collected today and that meant that I
had to go to the Saints breur but I'd
already planned cuz the Saints Brees was
next to the cricket pitch where I was
going to play didn't account for the
fact I wasn't going to be at the cricket
pitch I was going to be at the [__]
Royal Victoria infirmary like having a a
boot put on and then I realized I was
like right Dad I know that I've just had
the most traumatic injury of my entire
life thus far but we now need to leave
the rvi and go to Sainsbury's to collect
this [__] television or else this
very carefully put together House of
Cards is all going to come tumbling down
so yeah I've got a selfie with you in
the hospital you you wearing Cricket
whites correct I was still I had to be
cut out of my [__] Cricket my brand
new Cricket whites my mom was my mom was
dead I still you sent me a picture of it
with how's the bogy
cuz so bogy veryy a buggy that you just
squeeze where your K should be there was
just there was no it was just fles it
was just flesh I left foot drove home
from the rvi so I snapped my right foot
and my left foot drove home because I
was like I can't be bother going to get
my car tomorrow that's the better of
which is the variation where you over
pressed the break left left left left
left foot drove home bro accelerator and
break this is where life hacks episode
one has buy an automatic car yeah you're
the real winner that in a manual wow
yeah that's impossible that's game over
uh all right yeah that's good I like
that it's just one thing like tactically
how do you do that like what does that
look like on tick tick so just so you'll
learn in your private onet to one but
you just I I generally will like stack
the morning and then leave white space
in the afternoon cuz the morning stuff
always takes longer than you think and
then you I always and almost always
always end up with a little bit of extra
time at the endend of the day and you
can just take off a few bonus things and
if you leave with no if you finish today
with nothing on your tick tick feels
great that's nice it's like that that's
like a couple hundred quid a day in
happiness I think every day s so I've
got a mini lesson from you and a mini
lesson from you none from me well we've
we've kind of collabed on our lessons
today but you don't have to try and make
him feel more important to your lessons
than you are so I learned a lot from
George visiting him a couple of weeks
ago but one of the things that's
definitely clear here is that whenever
you run into a problem you derive a
principle from it you write about it and
create some content to kind of solidify
that lesson and you fail fast with
figuring out like how can I stress test
this problem so the midwit thing works
very well and the failing fast so I
experienced this cuz George took me
foiling which was excellent It's like a
motorized surfboard and on the way there
he said Yousef you're going to fall
spectacularly in the water 40 times
before you can consistently stand on the
foil so expect that so that you're not
just always disappointed with how badly
you're doing and having the bar set
there was great because then it meant
that I I'm not expecting to be good I
can have lots of spectacular Falls and
then if you manage to stand on it any
short any less than 40 after 40 fails
brilliant feels like a bonus so what's
the meta lesson The Meta lesson is pull
out the principles stress test them and
fail fast I think pricing in Failure is
so good pricing turns into video whereas
when I take people e for I give them
technical instructions they never listen
because it's their first time but that
one thing Always Rings home because
otherwise they try and stand up on the
first go fall off and go I'm a failure
and then each rep reinforces that versus
when you say you're going to fall off 40
times in a row they then see each one as
a rep like oh boom done the third one
done the fourth one yeah you I was
excited to fall the next time and
actually it took way less than 40 yeah
James Smith has a bit about this in his
live talk where he says he was knocking
door too for end power and realized that
every 200 door knocks he got a sale and
then his sales manager was like how many
more sales do you need for today and he
said two he like how many doors does it
take for you to get a sale went 200 he's
like well knock on 400 more [__]
doors then and it's just okay that's the
way to bake it in it's like just the
price of business basically 100% you say
you had a second one the lesson from you
is pick a thing and take it seriously so
that's something that's a Monga idea but
this podcast one okay it's this podcast
is The Testament to that we we started
our podcast in 2013 we picked a thing
among many things we didn't take it
seriously you did an episode with us in
2015 2016 you were like hm quite like
this and you were like I'm going to go
balls deep on this three episodes a week
well researched episodes aiming for good
production quality straight away and you
did the Reps and you enjoyed the process
as well you didn't just do it expecting
that like oh I'm on episode four why
hasn't this got more views yet or
whatever it was just I'm doing this to
master the craft and enjoy the process
and without being able to do that I'm
sure you would have given up way earlier
than you did and way earlier than the
well it's a lesson for all of the
Pursuits that we're all trying to do
that the person who enjoys walking Will
Walk Way further than the person that
has to walk yeah exactly so those are
the two matter lessons as much as I can
say would apply to everything what's
difficult is giving a prescription
without a diagnosis and I think this is
the problem with content in general that
without doing that you're kind of
scatter gunning stuff you're shotgunning
stuff because
um obviously in medicine to use that
analogy you always have a patient in the
room with a symptom a guiding principle
and you do history examination
investigation diagnosis treatment and if
you Shuffle those steps around you're
going to have a really low hit rate so
the the broader principles are as good
as we can get and then the the fastest
way to make faster progress is to work
with someone to diagnose what is my
bottleneck right now and how can I then
fix
that all right I think I'm going to do
one hack and one lesson quickly because
I can do that uh hack is Kindle released
this year their largest most expensive
Kindle yet which is the Kindle scribe
which has got a pen that comes with it
and it's all advertised as and you can
use this it'll replace your paper it's
kind of trying to compete with a
remarkable doesn't have the features of
remarkable like it's not it doesn't have
a a folio keyboard folder thing it's not
as advanced as that and like how many
times are you thinking you know I really
wish that I could like hand write a note
right now they're also trying to say
well you can hand annotate books but you
can't write on the margins or write on
the words you have to highlight tag a
note and then within the note that gives
you an area that you can write so for
the writing area stuff it's kind of
bollocks it's also if you haven't got a
paper white or an oasis yet and still
found yourself wanting more Kindle it's
not enough that being said it is
probably in terms of screen area maybe
even bigger than an A4 piece of paper so
you fit a ton of text and I didn't
realize how enjoyable reading long pages
of text is rather than moving through
pages a lot each time that I move a page
there's a nonzero chance that I'm going
to be like I'm at the top of another
page here and there's something about
it's very enjoyable for me personally as
well I have a habit of spinning a pen
through my fingers and it helps me Focus
if I do something small that distract a
little bit of physical energy from
myself I focus a lot more on whatever
I'm thinking about so the fact it's
always got this pen attached can do that
you can change page with the pen by
tapping it you can also highlight very
accurately by using the pen which is
something I use then that gets
resurfaced through readwise but I'm like
a power user when it comes to Kindle
send to Kindle is the way that I read
articles I don't read substacks on the
computer I don't read blog posts on the
computer all of that goes through Kindle
and it's it's just a huge monster piece
of Kit with a pen attached to it that
you can highlight and navigate with and
that's very enjoyable super bright uh is
it like an e Inc screen or is it like a
same like an iPad you can do like the
flux setting as well so for go super War
yeah going super I'm not at the 90day
Mark for it yet so I can't but it is I'm
60% of the way through elon's new
biography and I'm not even thought about
the charger I've got 86% battery battery
is insane I'll tell you what's an even
more insane way to do it turn it to
airplane mode turn a Kindle to airplane
mode and it it's INF it's an infinite
[__] uh energy machine it's crazy um
and then just a quick lesson which is
from Morgan house your expectations
Define your happiness more than your
circumstances uh if you presume that
happiness is what you want minus what
you have like a lot of billionaires are
broke and that
meta lesson of you can try and dial down
your expectations which is kind of hard
we're all type A people that want to
achieve a lot and not leave it on the
table but always just looking for that
reframe of
look why am I even bothered about
chasing this particular thing is it just
because I once saw this guy that I used
to go to whatever with or that I used to
know from this thing who's just done X
or Y or Zed or they're on in the SE
shells or he's got a Ferrari or the what
like all of that [__] just comes
back to like every time that you decide
to bring a desire into your life see it
as
a it's like a CLA of payment on
happiness it's like I'm going to if I
decide to bring this in I'm withdrawing
from an overdraft and I'm going to have
to repay that at some point like really
really carefully scrutinize desires and
expectations because
they're there delays unhappiness a great
meme for that is like net reality say
where you have net profit like reality
minus expectation net reality like if
someone has an incredible reality but
their expectations are greater they're a
minusy bit yeah that's in terms of it
something you skimmed over with
consuming content mindfully was that you
have a a read later app whatever that is
and you're only allowed to read from
that app so it stops you from reactively
just reading an article in one of the 20
tabs you've got open instead it has to
go through your established system Yeah
by doing that as well the center Kindle
thing it makes you very mindful it's
like do I want this on my Kindle library
page do I really want this on there
probably not and there's always more
stuff to read than time to read it in so
triaging what you have to read sent
Kindle plus scribe plus pen spinning
plus massive battery time in big screen
[__] I have to say I also bought
another Oasis uh so I now have Kindle
next to my bed and I have a Kindle
downstairs I have two Kindle devices I
found that moving them between the two I
would get into bed and I'm like
downstairs guess what I'm not reading
now like I'll watch Netflix or I'll
whatever um and the same vice versa for
a morning routine I'm like oh it's still
upstairs yeah I'll just skip reading
today it's like things in places I think
just one final thing on the expectations
thing that like the Ted Talk where
Paradox of choices and Barry Schwarz
yeah is it his Ted Talk yeah I think he
talks about like the key to happiness is
low expectations and I've always
struggled with that with actioning that
cuz the the happiness to increase your
happiness if you just decrease your
expectations do you guys have any
practical ways of doing that be careful
about what desires you let into your
life like expectations are always going
to be high for what you want but there's
ways that you can tune that up I could
definitely make your expectations higher
it's the inversion thing it's like how
do you reduce expectations all right how
do you increase expectations I would
spend tons of time on the internet
looking at people that are doing better
than me I'd see things that I don't want
and unquestioningly presume that I want
to have those things because they're
ahead of me in some form or another like
do you really want a private jet no but
if I look at someone that has one I go
oh yeah I should have a private jet and
it just gets added into that like but
but if you extend that it's like okay so
my like the people I spend all my time
with should be like the least successful
people I should find uh Gad sad you see
what I mean Gad sad found in his book
about happiness is most recent one that
uh you need to have a minimum amount of
sex per week in order to be happy but
the best way to be happy about your sex
life is to be having a little bit more
sex than the friends around you it's
like the thing of like you should be
more successful than your wife's sisters
husband yeah correct or whatever it is
and like as long as you're above that
chrushy gee so I've got I'll do a quick
Life Hack and I'll blast through my um
lesson so a quick life hack is most of
people listening to this probably or
significant amount have an iPhone and
the alarm clocks designed by Apple all
like Guantanamo Bay Creations from the
CIA they are horrific and the thought
that you'd wake up your sleep I've tried
like if you go through them all you
press every single one none of them are
like that's a nice soothing thing you'd
hear at they've all got a really high
attack on the sound haven't they Sy
cocktail what you can do if you go on
the custom tune Store and search b
neural beats it's 79p so it is a big
investment but 79p I found this like and
find the one that relaxes you and it's
such a better way if you you w up to
your iPhone what do you mean yeah that's
B that's probably a question that's a
[__] but you sleeping phone K phone
sleeping with your phone in your bedroom
yeah but I used to use an Alexa and then
I asked the news alarm clocks have been
around for nearly 100 years there's
about three Life Hack contentions That
across all of the stream a lot of people
listening to this will be using their
iPhone and that is a useful one this is
the midwit meme don't use the phone
don't try and repurpose the phone alarm
to be more successful get rid of the
phone and buy uh either Sunrise alarm
clock you can get one on Amazon for 15
bucks or standard radio alarm clock
five5 you know there's one called I
think it's called like Clocky now that
has wheels on it so it's an alarm clock
and then as soon as it's sets off it
starts driving around you have to get
few there's one that's a mat you have to
stand on it and solve a math problem
[__] that be such a bad hanger does
anyone I don't use an alarm I just wake
up
my like just go to bed at the same time
it's easy yeah that's not always anyway
shut up Johnny lesson so so far I've
done a lesson from um little obviously
throwback to Monga Bezos this one um
comes from the gallager brothers Liam
and null nice so they have a lyric which
hits me every single time I think it's
the best lyric I've ever heard which is
questions are the answers you might
need and it hits me hard so um
essentially even when I have people ask
me for advice now or even when I'm
thinking myself or even creating content
just having a recurring question that I
come back to is so useful versus having
a specific answer so you avoid the
prescriptions mindset one of the things
um is this Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy I know if you heard that and they
within that they create a super computer
which like supposed to give them the
answers to life and the universe and it
just spits back 42 and it's like cuz you
didn't know what the question was and so
many things I come back to questions now
so have you read elon's uh book yet so I
mean I can tell you it right now this is
what it is okay it's basically him he
comes up an idea and then somebody works
from him and go that's not possible and
he goes does it defy the laws of physics
and then they like well not technically
he goes but we still can't do it he goes
why why why and then he hits the base
level belief and goes fix that and then
he goes also do it by next Tuesday and
it's like build a rocket it's it's that
it's just him going does it defy the
laws of physics and then they go no I go
I want it done by next Friday it's just
it's just a question does it defy the
laws of physics and then deadline that's
that is the 100 anecdotes is the book
just doing that again again again so
does it defy the laws of physics is a
question um one of my favorite things
right now is I have friends come to me
for advice and I'd often used to like
get super detailed and give them so much
advice and people wouldn't listen and I
was like okay so what I do now is I'm
just like what would you advise me if I
came to you in the exact same situation
you you diddled me with this in Dubai
yeah diddled me with it in an Uber yeah
and it works and they come up with
something that's so profound and
personalized that hits home versus me
trying to give them generic things and
the Tony robbin's like what will you do
and I don't know well if you did know
why would it be that that works every
time unbelievable yeah which what we
said earlier when we had a quick toilet
break that uh if you have bad breath
you're the only person in the room that
doesn't know but as soon as somebody
else has bad breath you do know and it's
the ability when you take them out of
that frame and have a a question it's
given them the answer that they needed
all along and then a few other favorite
questions that I have at the minute
which is where if you meet somebody
who's way smarter than you asking them
the question of well what question
should I be asking you is a great one
another one which is kind of a test
right now in where people often end up
in super tribalistic thinking of team
this team over here or this team over
here I can tell whether someone's a
fullon NPC by whether they can answer
this question which is who is somebody
you admire and you get them to answer
that like who's your kind of cult hero
and he goes what do you disagree with
them on or what's their worst point that
they make and then the inverse too like
who's somebody you strongly dislike and
what's a great point that they have and
you find people who are really high at
critical thinking or have really thought
it through from both sides can answer
that really fast but a lot of people
just like the thought of them conceding
a point to somebody on the opposing team
correct or being able to criticize their
Guru it the the software just hits a 404
error very fast monor thinking gentlemen
I really appreciate you coming through
uh it's been a wild year for you guys
and for me and for you as well although
you're less traumatized than we are so
you seem you seem to be able to deal
with it deal with it more effectively uh
it goes without saying everyone that's
been tuning in
for any of the episodes where you used
to see us sitting on this couch uh I
really appreciate you for tuning in I
hope you have a fantastic Christmas this
is going to go out two days before
Christmas so we can say Merry Christmas
to everybody Merry Christmas and uh yeah
you going to finish on Last Christmas
he's going to sing the whole thing out
is that what you're here for that's what
you promis put the glasses on uh I
appreciate you all have a Merry
Christmas we'll catch you soon Merry
Christmas bye